[Music]  it was one thing you could do would  change your life for the better  oh that's easy I would be able to see  Catherine from downstairs I can make  things happen  clothes and dress taught me all I have  to do is wave my hand  Dennis be able to speak kiss kiss please  please please  nothing else matters come to think of it  I wouldn't mind shagging your leg right  now I could solve every problem in the  world if you thought this thing through  dog mask loser and a really big  obviously I was being selfish gonna make  people happy everyone who died be alive  you may be President of the United  States  here are the briefing papers for Syria  the deficit Israel in the Middle East  just pretend to be a dumb animal again I  love you new shut up - agnya give me the  body of a great man  [Music]